♪ ♪
>> Greg: YOU HEAR A LOT ABOUT
SYSTEMIC RACISM IN AMERICA.
IF YOU DON’T AGREE, YOU ARE
PROOF OF THE PROBLEM.
IT’S AN ACCUSATION THAT PREVENTS
YOU FROM MOUNTING A DEFENSE,
WHICH LEADS TO ACTUAL SYSTEMIC
RACISM IN OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM,
AS A PRETENSE TO ERADICATE IT.
ONE NEW YORK CITY SCHOOL HAS
ASKED PARENTS TO RANK THEIR
WHITENESS, FROM WHITE SUPREMACY
TO WHITE ABOLITIONIST.
HOW IS THAT NOT SYSTEMIC RACISM?
IF YOU DISAGREE, AREN’T YOU
PROOF OF THE PROBLEM?
THE OREGON DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION CONCLUDED THAT ASKING
STUDENTS TO SHOW THEIR WORK IN
MATH CLASS IS EVIDENCE OF WHITE
SUPREMACY.
THIS WOULD BE LAUGHABLE IF IT
WEREN’T SO DAMAGING.
ON A GLOBAL MATH RANKINGS,
AMERICA’S 25TH.
WHO’S ON TOP OF READING,
SCIENCE, AND MATH?
IT RHYMES WITH CHINA.
INSTEAD OF LESSONS IN SOMETHING
THAT MATTERS, WE LET THESE
GOBBLE UP OUR KIDS.
THEN THERE’S THE TEACHERS WHO
PROBABLY NEVER READ SHAKESPEARE,
DEMANDING THEY CUT HIM FROM
COURSES, BECAUSE HE IS A TOOL OF
WHITE OPPRESSION.
REMEMBER THAT SAN FRANCISCO
SCHOOL BOARD WANTED TO RENAME
THOSE SCHOOLS?
WE LAUGHED, BUT THEY WERE
SERIOUS.
THEY DELAYED IT REOPENING
CLASSROOMS TO TACKLE THIS
PRIORITY.
THIS HAS BECOME THE NEW
CURRICULUM.
RACE WARFARE USING IDENTITY
POLITICS TO GIVE POWER TO A
CLICK OF PETTY DICTATORS.
IT’S BRAINWASHING AND WASHES
AWAY THE BRAINS.
THEY ARE SPENDING YOUR TAX
DOLLARS TO MAKE YOUR KID DUMBER.
CNN CAN DO THAT FOR FREE.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE SCHOOL
BOARD, AND WE THOUGHT THEY ARE
MARGINAL, WON’T HAVE AN IMPACT.
THEY’RE GOING TO DELAY
DISCUSSING PUTTING KIDS BACK IN
CLASS, AND TACKLED THE NAME
CHANGE FIRST.
>> Juan: I DON’T THINK THAT’S
RIGHT.
THAT PRIORITY IS OUT OF PLACE.
IT’S ABOUT GETTING KIDS BACK IN
SCHOOL FIRST AND FOREMOST.
TO ME, THEY ARE MARGINAL IN SOME
WAYS.
I DON’T THINK THIS WOULD GO IN
MOST OF THE COUNTRY.
TO YOUR LARGER POINT, I THINK WE
ARE MORE DIVERSE THAN EVER.
YOU SEE RISING NUMBERS OF
MINORITIES, ESPECIALLY
HISPANICS, ASIANS IN AMERICAN
SOCIETY.
WITH THAT COMES PEOPLE WHO
DIDN’T HAVE A VOICE BEFORE,
ASKING TO BE HEARD.
ALSO PUTS PRESSURE ON THE
MAJORITY POPULATION, WHITE
AMERICA, BECAUSE THEY ARE ASKED
TO BE MORE AWARE OF HOW THEY
TREAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
WHITE IN THIS SOCIETY.
TO ASK THEM TO THINK ABOUT HOW
THEY DEAL WITH THE OTHER.
I DON’T THINK "RACIST."
RIGHT NOW, THERE’S A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE ANTIRACIST IN THIS SOCIETY
SOCIETY.
IT MEANS BEING AGGRESSIVELY,
LOOKING FORWARD, TAKING A STEP
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE TREATED EQUALLY.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S A BAD THING
THING.
>> Greg: I THINK YOU MIGHT BE
SOFT PEDDLING THIS A BIT.
THIS IS MORE LIKE AN
INDOCTRINATION.
IF YOU DISAGREE, YOU ARE IN
TROUBLE.
>> Katie: I DON’T THINK THE
MAJORITY OF WHITE AMERICANS SEE
PEOPLE DIFFERENT THAN THEM AS
THE OTHER.
THINK MOST PEOPLE TREAT THEM AS
FELLOW AMERICANS, THEIR FRIENDS,
AND WITH RESPECT, INSTEAD OF
TREATING THEM AS THE OTHER,
LOOKING AT THEM DIFFERENTLY
BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN, WHERE THEY ARE FROM.
I KNOW WE’VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
SCHOOLS COME BUT MAYBE WE SHOULD
KEEP THEM CLOSED.
STUDENTS ARE NOT ENGAGED.
I REMEMBER THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC, TEACHERS DIDN’T WANT
PARENTS SITTING IN ON THEIR
KID’S PRISM GLASSES?
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE
TEACHING IN KID’S SCHOOL
CLASSES?
YOU ARE PAYING FOR EVERY PENNY
OF IT, WHICH IS WHAT TEACHERS
ARE FIGHTING SCHOOL CHOICE.
THERE ARE ALTERNATIVE, REAL
EDUCATIONS THEY SHOULD BE
GETTING.
>> Greg: IF YOU COUPLE THIS
DEVELOPMENT WITH WHAT’S BEEN
HAPPENING, COMING OUT OF
CAMPUSES, WITH THE PANDEMIC,
THIS SEEMS LIKE AN IDEAL TIME
FOR A NATIONAL RETHINK ON THE
FUTURE OF EDUCATION.
WHAT CAN WE DO?
>> ANY TIME THERE’S BEEN A
PANDEMIC OR PLAGUE, THERE’S
ALWAYS BEEN SOME BIG, MASSIVE
CHANGE.
THE POINT YOU MADE ABOUT THE
OREGON DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
SEGMENT SHOWING YOUR WORK IN
MATH IS WHITE SUPREMACY, WE ARE
MAKING THIS FOR OUR OWN BACK.
THESE KIDS ARE THE FUTURE OF
THIS COUNTRY.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
COMPETE.
YOUNG PEOPLE MIGHT THINK "WHAT A
BUNCH OF OLD PEOPLE, THEY DON’T
UNDERSTAND."
BELIEVE US.
IT’S A COMPETITIVE WORLD, WE
HAVE TO ACT LIKE IT IN OUR
SCHOOLS.
COLLEGES, STUDENT AT -- I FEEL
LIKE WE DO NOT SPEND ENOUGH TIME
TALKING ABOUT K-12.
>> I’M GOING TO TRY TO OVERLOOK
YOUR FOUL LANGUAGE.
THIS IS A FAMILY SHOW.
WE ARE GOING TO [BLEEP] YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
JESSE, YOU ARE THE MOST WOKE
PERSON AT FOX.
THIS CAN’T BE GOOD.
THEY’RE GOING TO EAT OUR LUNCH
IN THE 20-30 YEARS.
>> Dana: THAT’S WHAT BIDEN
SAID.
>> Jesse: THE MOST OFFENSIVE
THING ABOUT THIS IS THE SCHOOL
TRYING TO GIVE PARENTS HOMEWORK.
IF YOU ARE NOT SENDING ME
HOMEWORK!
I’M NOT TAKING HOMEWORK TO
REFLECT ON MY WHITENESS, MY
BLACKNESS, WHATEVER.
I’M DONE REFLECTING.
I’M WORKING.
YOU REFLECT ON HOW YOU CAN MAKE
MY SON OR DAUGHTER GET INTO A
GREAT COLLEGE SO I DON’T HAVE TO
GREASE THE UNIVERSITY WITH A
GENEROUS DONATION.
[LAUGHTER]
IF I WANT TO REFLECT ON HOW BAD
MY RACE IS, I CAN WATCH CNN ALL
DAY.
[LAUGHTER]
THIS IS AN ATTACK ON WESTERN
CIVILIZATION.
IT HAS CONTRIBUTED SO MUCH TO
THE WORLD, THE AMERICAN
EXPERIMENT IN TERMS OF
PROSPERITY, INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS,
FREEDOM.
THERE IS NO PROBLEM WITH ADDING
MORE VOICES TO WESTERN
CIVILIZATION, BLACK VOICES,
HISPANIC VOICES.
WE DON’T NEED TO TEAR DOWN
WESTERN CIVILIZATION LIKE MATH
AND SHAKESPEARE AND ABE LINCOLN
TO ACCOMPLISH CREATING MORE
DIVERSITY.
WE CAN JUST ADD MORE VOICES.
THAT’S NOT THREATENING ANYBODY.
>> FOR THE PAST MINUTE OR TWO,